ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich aus dem haus
der religionen in bern zu einer weiteren
ausgabe unserer streitfragen heute zum thema
für alle gleichgeschlechtliche paare sollen
in der schweiz bald heiraten dürften so will es
die rechtskommission des nationalrates wie aber
beurteilen christliche gemeinschaften und kirchen
de für alle der schönste tag im leben soll sie
sein die hochzeit die verbindung von mann und
frau vor gott und seit 1875 auch vor dem gesetz
doch die fortschreitende säkularisierung macht
vor dem altar nicht halt in den letzten zehn
jahren ging in die kirchlichen trauungen in der
schweiz ungefähr um einen drittel zurück dennoch
heiraten noch immer viele paare in der kirche
heterosexuelle paare homosexuelle können ihre
partnerschaft eintragen lassen heiraten können
sie nicht das bedeutet wenn ein heterosexuelles
paar heiratet können sie die beiden vermögen
zusammen liegen als gütegemeinschaft homosexuelle
paare dürfen das nicht bei einer ehe zwischen
mann und frau kann ein ausländischer partner
erleichtert eingebürgert werden und so
den schweizer pass einfacher bekommen
bei einem gleichgeschlechtlichen paar geht
das nicht und auch bezüglich witwenrente ist
eine verheiratete heterosexuelle frau bevorzugt
gegenüber einer in registrierte partnerschaft
lebenden lesbischen frau im todesfall der
partnerin bekommt sie im unterschied zur
verheirateten frau nur eine witwenrente wenn
sie minderjährige kinder hat sonst nicht
gleichgeschlechtliche paare können also in der
schweiz noch nicht heiraten im unterschied zu
vielen europäischen ländern doch nun liegt
ein gesetzesentwurf vor die große mehrheit
der rechtskommission des nationalrats hat ihn
just am valentinstag in die vernehmlassung
geschickt in christlichen kirchen herrscht
in dieser frage uneinigkeit soll die ehe für
alle auch vor gott vollzogen werden dürfen
wer ist einer kirchlichen traum oder eines
ehe sakraments würdig und wer nicht und warum
nicht zu unserer diskussion begrüße ich ganz
herzlich hier in der runde regula lehmann
sie ist diplomierte familienhelferin leitet
den bereich ehe und familien projekte bei der
stiftung zukunft ch sie ist reformiert und hat
einen freiheitlichen hintergrund eva cavalli
hebamme vom dachverband regenbogenfamilien
gehört zur evangelisch methodistischen kirche
der schweiz manfred plog römisch katholischer
theologe professor für pastoraltheologie
an der theologischen hochschule in chur
und sie bevor theologin evangelisch
reformierte pfarrerin in kilchberg
sie will vor segnen sie gleichgeschlechtliche
paare ich segne gleichgeschlechtliche paare
das ist in der zürcher kirchenordnung schon
seit längerem erlaubt segnungsfeier nen für
gleichgeschlechtliche paare bedürfnis und das
ist theologischer unsinn nicht trauung nennen
aber eine reformierte trauung ist nichts anderes
als eine segnungsfeier aber dass es zeigt mit dem
verhältnis von kirche und staat zusammen der
staat entscheidet zu recht wer zivilrechtlich
die ehe schließen darf und wir was von der kirche
her dürfen nur trauen wer eben zivilrechtlich die
ehe schließen durfte dh wenn die ehe für alle
kommt kommt auch zumindest für die reformierten
kirchen mit größter wahrscheinlichkeit und auch
in meiner hoffnung die trauben für alle also das
kennen ja viele die kirchlich geheiratet haben
wir es kommt die zivile trauung dann die kirche
besetzt erklärt aber sie sagen segnung und traum
ist für sie dann gerade das gleiche da theologisch
gesehen reformiert theologisch gesehen ist das
dasselbe genau grimm manfred plog katholischer
theologe die katholische kirche gilt ja als
bewahrerin schlechthin de vom eben mann und
frau sind sich die katholikinnen und katholiken
eigentlicher heimisch ich habe man muss sehen
kirche ist ja nicht nur das kirchliche lehre und
leitungsamt sondern zunächst mal die gemeinschaft
der gläubigen die auch ihre eigene meinung sich
bildet natürlich sind wir da kommen wir aus einer
tradition wo wir den wert der verbindung von frau
und mann sehr hoch schätzen ist sogar katholisch
als sakrament bezeichnen das finde ich gut
trotzdem bleibt für mich die frage ob wir nicht
die zeichen der zeit auch wahrnehmen dass menschen
egal welcher sexuellen orientierung genauso diesen
schritt gehen können wenn sich theologisch davon
ausgehe dass gott jeden menschen liebt und daneben
auch mit der jeweiligen sexuellen orientierung und
sie stellen als frage was sie vom verein würden
also sieht man sagen je für alle nein was ist für
sie denn das wichtigste argument die ehe ist etwas
gewachsenes ein wichtiges argument ist für mich
die schöpfungslehre die schöpfung theologie kann
sicher aber auch dass ich etwas ist was länder
kultur religionsübergreifend auch für die große
mehrheit von menschen mann frau mit dem potenzial
auch kinder zu haben bedeutet und von daher finde
ich möchte diesen begriff nicht für alle öffnen
das sehen sie beim sommers wahlkampagne warum das
sehe ich ganz anders weil liebe ist liebe also
die liebe zu meiner frau ist die gleiche liebe
wie die liebe von innen frau lehmann zu ihrem mann
da bin ich total überzeugt und unsere gesetze in
der schweiz hinken dem hinterher sie bilden meine
realität nicht ob ich durfte so eine segnungsfeier
erleben mit meiner frau vor 16 jahren und das
war wirklich der schönste tag im leben von mir
aber ich würde sehr gerne auch ein drittes mal
heiraten dürfen weil wir waren zuerst im kanton
zürich und dann in der schweiz und würde sehr
gerne ein drittes hochzeitsfest feiern sie leben
mit ihrer partnerin in einer eingetragenen
partnerschaft sie wonach ihren christlichen
glauben leben das war beim weiter weg dahin das
war er können sie uns davon etwas erzählen ich
bin in einem reformiert christlichen haushalt
familie aufgewachsen und ich war lange auch in
eine freikirche und bin da groß geworden und habe
das wiso mitbekommen dass homosexualität ist sünde
und aus ich daneben gemerkt habe dass ich mich in
die sarah verliebt habe das war ganz schwierig für
mich ich habe lange gekämpft und gebetet und für
mich beten lassen und nach zwei jahren kam ich
zum punkt zu sagen ich glaube es ist so gott hat
mich so geschaffen und wir versuchen es zusammen
zu leben und ich bin froh dass diese liebe immer
noch anhält sie waren damals in einer freikirche
da hat das aber dann nicht mehr funktioniert
habe ich das richtig im grunde genau aber wir
mussten diese freikirche auch zu lassen also das
wurde uns nahegelegt wir haben aber den selber
die entscheidung getroffen dass wir austreten und
und jetzt zum glück haben wir in zürich in einer
methodistischen kirche eilig wieder heimat
gefunden und sind seit vier jahren mitglied
und ganz also auch so als paar akzeptiert und das
ist gar kein thema also es sind sicher nicht alle
total davon überzeugt dass wir das so leben aber
es ist auch wie es gar keine diskussion dass wir
da mitglieder sein dürfen und auch zu unserer
beziehung stehen können es geht ihnen durch
den kopf für die dazu gerne etwas sagen für mich
geht es nicht um die definition von liebe es geht
mir nicht darum die liebe von menschen qualitativ
zu denn das kann man ja gar nicht sie können die
liebe die ich zu meinem mann habe nicht beurteilen
und ich sage auch nicht dass die tiefer ist als
ihre liebe jetzt ihre partnerin es geht nicht
darum es geht für mich um die frage wie definieren
wir den begriff ich glaube das muss man trennen
weil man kann gefühle schlichtweg nicht irgendwie
beurteilen das war mir wichtig zusammen aber jetzt
doch mal nachgefragt wenn sie sagen ich bin gegen
die ehe für alle wie wäre denn das für menschen
die eben gleichgeschlechtlich lieben ihren glauben
aber auch leben wollen in gemeinschaften wo dann
ihnen gesagt wird das geht nicht das löst eine
spannung aus das verstehe ich wenn wir aber in den
bereich des glaubens gehen die reformation hat uns
diese das neue gebracht dass wir die bibel lesen
dass sie sich selber lesen dass das volk die bibel
liest und für mich hat diese bibel auch eine
hohe autorität und was ich darin erkenne auch
als persönliche wahrheit das ist ja immer auch
ein persönlicher weg ich setze auch nicht meine
erkenntnis als absolut aber was ich darin erkenne
dem gehe ich nach das versuche ich nach bestem
wissen und gewissen umzusetzen auch in meinem
leben das ist auch für mich nicht immer gefährlich
die bergpredigt ist keine gefällige schöne
geschichte das fordert auch mich heraus aber jedes
dass eine überzeugungs frage und die löst spannung
aber ich glaube aber auch dass diese spannung zu
unserem leben gehört wenn wir die einfach auflösen
dann sind wir auch nicht mehr ehrlich und mir ist
es wichtig in beziehungen ehrlich zu sein auch mit
meinen kindern jetzt erwachsen sind da finden wir
auch nicht alles immer toll uns gut dass die
machen aber ich habe diese auseinandersetzung
die müssen wir führen auch aus kirchen und kirchen
definieren dass er dann auch ganz unterschiedlich
auch nach ihrer erkenntnis die man ich bin sehr
dafür dass wir als christinnen und christen uns
auf die bibel als das grund dokumente unseres
glaubens beziehen aber da geht es ja gerade darum
dass gott zum beispiel die heiligkeit einer jeden
lebens und beziehungsgeschichte achtet warum fällt
uns schwer in der bibel auch der hat sich die
vorstellung von ehe von partnerschaft entwickelt
und ich sehe dem ehe begriff nichts genommen und
er wird eher geöffnet wenn auf die bekommen wir
noch zu sprechen aber würden sie eher sagen ich
habe ihnen das als frage herausgehört sie haben
gesagt in der katholischen kirche ich kann mich
erinnern wie es eventuell im buch wie ein pfarrer
in bürglen man ein gleichgeschlechtliches paar
zwei fragen gesegnet das gab einen riesen aufstand
er musste danach zurückrudern also ich denke er
würde heute noch sagen ich stehe dazu aber der
verein sehen müssen der stand kurz davor seinen
job zu verlieren also das ist schon realität in
der römisch katholischen kirche würden sie denn
sagen es ist einfach gewissensentscheidung 1 denn
der einzelnen paare oder wie würden sie sagen
es braucht beides die einzelnen paare müssen für
sich entscheiden was ist für mich und für uns
miteinander stimmig und das kirchliche lehramt
muss sich weiterentwickeln also wenn wir nach
den zeichen der zeit fragen dann muss ich an der
weiterentwicklung sehen ehrliches beim start ist
er sagt wir müssen die wirklichkeit mit abbilden
wenn in der schweiz zehn prozent habe ich gelesen
der menschen homosexuell und lesbisch sind dann
kann ich nicht daran vorbeigehen beim start ist
es noch relativ einfacher der muss gucken wie
kann ich der verbindlichkeit wie kann ich
die regeln und auch rechtsrahmen schaffen
der den leuten sicherheit gibt und gerade die
schwächeren stützt bei den kirchen fällig wäre
es in der hinsicht sogar einfacher dass sie vom
jetzt gehe ich mal von ihrem gedanken aus vom
liebes gebot her sagen das allerwichtigste ist
wie menschen miteinander umgehen und nicht in
welcher form ich bin als reformierte theologie
natürlich sehr bei ihnen wenn es darum geht die
autorität der biblischen schriften zu erkennen und
hier habe ich irgendwie meine großen fragezeichen
sie finden in den biblischen schriften keine
einzige stelle die homosexuelle partnerschaften
ablehnt es gibt die ablehnung von homosexuellen
sexualakt es gibt keine die bibel kennt keine
homosexuellen liebesbeziehungen das ist nicht das
thema und sowieso ist in der biblischen schriften
ist homosexualität und absolutes randthema in den
evangelium überhaupt kein thema das wird manchmal
media so aufgeblasen dass man das gefühl hatte
die biblischen schriften seien ein einziges trat
traktat gegen homosexualität das ist nicht so
es gibt keine ablehnung in der bibel wichtige
bemerkung wir haben über den begriff gesprochen
ich habe versprochen wir kommen darauf zurück
dürfte ich noch kurz klären in der runde was
ist eigentlich mit für alle gemeint wir sind
alle zwei menschen zwei erwachsene menschen die
sich lieben zwei männer zwei frauen ein mann und
eine frau es wird niemandem es wird niemandem
nur ein prozent weggenommen wenn die ehe für
alle für alle kommt und ist es doch es dürfen
alle frauen und männer genauso weiter heiraten
also es sind die bereiche heraus sind paare
gemeint parlamentarische initiative schließt
ja wohngemeinschaften explizit als oder das
nur noch zur klärung also ich finde gut die
formulierung in der deutschen gesetzesvorlage
die haben dass er am ersten juli vor zwei jahren
im bundestag verabschiedet und daher ist es
ganz nüchtern die ehe schließen zwei personen
verschiedenen oder gleichen geschlechts das
finde ich angenehm nüchtern ohne bewertung
wichtig ist dass die beiden für sich in frei
hat diese entscheidung getroffen haben und
dann kommt für mich eher darauf an wie ist
die beziehungsqualität zwischen menschen und
wo können wir da helfen das zu unterstützen sobald
die erste runde hier der eindruck es ist eben ein
strittiges thema das war auch der grund dass wir
gesagt haben wir wollen erst einmal hier auf dem
podium die christlichen stimmen zusammen haben
und nicht noch andere religionen dazu nehmen
aber wir sind hier im haus der religionen und ich
geh maria zum nebentisch im haus der religionen
sind verschiedene nichtchristliche andere
religionsgemeinschaften zu hause gerne haug sitzt
hier sie ist eine der gründerinnen dieses hauses
hier der religionen sie war auch zehn jahre lang
präsidentin des fördervereines haus der religionen
ist denn dieses thema hilfe alle wird das hier im
haus diskutiert ja sicher warum nicht oder also
wir sind acht religionen unter einem dach aber
nicht unter einer käseglocke oder also das heißt
eben wir sind wirklich teil der gesellschaft und
hier sind die verschiedensten leute und wir
haben auch hier das ganze spektrum denke ich
an einstellungen aber es schon heißes eisen oder
ehe für alle für die religionen ich denke dass
das einfach ein thema ist es vielleicht auch ein
bisschen eine generationenfrage eine frage der
ersten oder zweiten generation der einwanderung
und so aber es ist klar dass das spektrum der
meinungen da sich ja ganz weit ist und das ist
ja auch das spannendes einer der gründe warum
wir hier so etwas machen wir verstehen uns
auch als ein bisschen als laboratorium des
friedlichen zusammenlebens und das heißt dass wir
dadurch dass wir auch unter einem dach leben dass
wir eben ins gespräch kommen aber ganz partner im
allgemeinen ganz pragmatisch auch über sehr heiße
themen auch über ganz schwierige konflikte also es
klingt so wie auf dem podium ganz unterschiedliche
positionen ja und ich denke kommt dann noch dazu
das ist auch eine erfahrung die wir macht sie
haben jetzt die christlichen vertreter da dass
es eine weitere erfahrungen die wir machen ist
das eigentlich die interreligiöse dialoge viel
schwieriger sind noch als die interreligiösen
dialog das sind ja ist er mal das gespräch
über die grenzen der religionsgemeinschaften
staat eigentlich ist eine halb also die gespräche
finden stahl aber es ist schwieriger innerhalb der
gleichen religion weil die erwartungen natürlich
auch immer auch emotionale ist auch der muss doch
so sein wie ich oder die musste ich bin gehört
zur gleichen religion neben ihnen sitzt umwelt
mehmeti sind hier im haus der religion auch im
moschee verein engagiert wie ist es da unter
der musliminnen und muslimen wie wir das thema
diskutiert also muss sagen dass die überwiegende
meinung der muslime ist dass die religiöse mann
und frau vorbehalten ist was die ziele angeht ist
der diskurs eigentlich fast inexistent also auch
sehr schwach das hat mehrere gründe ich denke der
hauptgrund ist auch dass die kommunen die haut
ist muslimische community erst in der ersten oder
zweiten generation hier in der schweiz lebt und
die politische partizipation auch dementsprechend
schwach ist und dementsprechend auch die
bereitschaft über aktuelle politische themen zu
diskutieren weniger stark vorhanden ist ich denke
aber dass aus zwei gründen dass wir muslime diese
diese vorlage auch unterstützen sollten erstens es
liegt absolut in unserem interesse als minderheit
in unserer demokratischen pluralistischen
gesellschaft wenn andere minderheiten jetzt
in unserem fall die homosexuellen bürger mehr
rechte erhalten ihre rechtsstellung verbessert
werden das ist der erste punkt und der zweite
grund ist eigentlich wenn man sich die das
rechtsinstitut anschaut und die wichtigsten
elemente heraus nimmt beispielsweise das
eingehen einer lebensgemeinschaft verantwortung
übernehmen für einander soziale absicherung treue
und beistand leisten das können homosexuelle paare
mindestens genau so gut wie heterosexuelle paare
ich glaube da würde mir auch die meisten leute wir
auch zustimmen ein offenes wort sind auch der sohn
des imams sicht auf das offenlegen hier in der
moschee von moscheevereinen hast religion gibt es
da zwischen den generationen ein unterschied dass
die jüngeren das offener sehen ich denke schon
ich denke schon dass die jüngere generation der
offene gegenübersteht ja wir haben jetzt gehört
eben auch bei den muslimen muslimen sie haben
es gesagt bei der gemeinschaft niemals wird die
frage für alle kontrovers diskutiert werden haben
sie auch gehört bereits in der einstiegs- und auf
dem podium bei konservativen katholikinnen und
katholiken ist der fall klar sie sind gegen die
ehe für alle ich habe vor der sendung den abt vom
kloster maria stein im kanton solothurn täter von
suri getroffen herab beurteilen sie die ehe
für alle ich denke so eine modeerscheinung
und es ist nicht das wichtigste thema unserer
gesellschaft ich habe meine man den eindruck es
werde von eine sehr aktive minderheiten mehrheit
auch auf gedrückt was spricht denn aus sicht der
römisch katholischen kirche gegen die eta
in der christlichen tradition er ganz klar
als einen ehebund eine lebensgemeinschaft von
mann und frau der definitionen und das ist für
mich gültig und die kirche lehrt eigentlich seit
anfang an dass die ehe in der schöpfung begründet
liegt also nicht eine erfindung der kirchen
und die kirche hat während jahrhunderten die
e-modelle der gesellschaft übernommen damit die
zeit als vertieft auch die rogge vertieft und
dann auch noch eine die sakramentale dimension
hinein gebracht haben ist ein anderes kapitel
grundsätzlich auch von der kulturgeschichte honda
anthropologie scheint wir absolut sinnvoll und
legitim zu sein dass ehe ist ein bund zwischen
mann und frau und wenn jetzt zwei männer oder
zwei fallen zu ihnen kommen diese sind gläubig
wir wollen uns auch kirchlich trauen was sagen
sie dann dann muss ich sagen das geht nicht also
da schenke ich den leuten wirklich klaren wein
ein und sage ich werde sie nicht trauen aber jetzt
und wenn sie das akzeptieren können dann schauen
wir weiter was können wir machen aber es ist mir
gar nicht sympathisch leuten irgendwelche tricks
vorspielt um dann meint man könne sie irgendwie
hereinholen das ist nicht meine linie ja peter von
suri sagt eine minderheit ist so etwas deutlicher
will einer mehrheit etwas diktieren ich sehe das
nicht so das vorzeichen vor der klammer ist schon
ungünstig wenn er das bewertet als das seine mode
erscheinung dann denke ich nämlich die menschen
nicht ernst für die das wichtig ist und ich habe
für mich gelernt man muss unterscheiden ob
ich dinge jetzt theoretisch am schreibtisch
verdenken und da natürlich auch er hat ja von der
entwicklung gesprochen die ist auch anzuerkennen
aber auch zu gucken wie kann es weitergehen also
ich lerne durch konkrete begegnungen und ich kann
mich gut erinnern wie ich im jahre 2000 beim
ersten ökumenischen kirchentag in berlin war
und dann sah ich einen stand haruka homosexuelle
und kirche dachte wunderbar kannst dich mal gleich
informieren stand der schüchtern am tisch und
schaut wer die infos an und plötzlich stehen da
zwei junge sympathische männer mir gegenüber
können wir da helfen ich war etwas verlegen
und kommt mit den ins gespräch die machen auf
mich einen sehr glaubwürdigen eindruck dass sie
ihre beziehung wichtig wenn das sie als christen
leben wollen und dann habe ich spontan gedacht ja
verbinde ich dass ich sage geht nicht darf nicht
ja und umso mehr habe ich mich dann gefreut dass
14 jahre später partsch franziskus bei irgendeinem
rückflug das im flugzeug auch gesagt hat das heißt
die konkrete begegnung mit menschen verbietet
dann einfach schlicht von modeerscheinung zu
reden also ich schätze ab von syrer das nicht
das problem aber so einfach glaube ich darf man
damit nicht umgehen also für mich ich möchte
zurück zu den gesellschaftlichen veränderungen
ich glaube wichtig ist da für mich dass die kirche
vom ewigen redet klar die kirche muss nicht per se
sich gesellschaftlichen veränderungen anpassen die
kirche muss es nicht geschafft recht machen die
kirche hat den auftrag ist gott recht zu machen
die kirche ist nicht dem zeitgeist verpflichtet
sondern die kirche ist gott verpflichtet also ich
finde die argumentation dass sich die gesellschaft
verändert egal bei welchem thema jetzt dass
geht mir jetzt gar nicht nur einfach um die
ehe für alle das ist für mich nicht die kirche zu
der ich gehören möchte die von der gesellschaft
von bewegungen gesteuert wird frau leben haben ich
wir haben als katholiken im zweiten vatikanischen
konzil ausdrücklich gesagt freude und hoffnung
trauer und angst der menschen müssen unsere
freude und angst und trauer sein das heißt wenn
wir die fragen der menschen nicht zulassen und
die uns zu eigen machen können wir unmöglich als
anspruch erheben wir wollten anwalt der menschen
sagen das hat nichts mit zeitgeist zu tun das ist
so einfach dass heißt liegt das nun fragen nicht
zuletzt die frage ist welche antworten gibt man
darauf ich will nur sagen grundsätzlich glaube
ich nicht dass die kirche sich gesellschaftliche
veränderungen anpassen muss es für sie die kirche
das kirchliche lehramt allein katholische kirche
die reformierte kirche auch die gläubigen auch
ich muss mich nicht ich bin nicht verpflichtet
mich gesellschaftlichen entwicklungen anzupassen
indem ich zustimme ich nehme diese entwicklungen
war und ich bilde mir eine meinung und ich habe
eine haltung dazu gut das war das argument von
von sony also sie würden von kirchen sprechen
weil da keine einen halt herrscht aber ich über
spitzes mal sie würden sagen die 68er hatten die
freie liebe jetzt kommt irgendwie de für alle die
kirche soll nicht jede mode mitmachen ist es so in
die richtung oder nein ich möchte einfach dabei
ich möchte jetzt das jetzt gar nicht auf diese
modeerscheinung oder so übertragen oder was jetzt
so flapsig sagen sondern einfach die kirche muss
muss ist gott recht machen das ist das kriterium
hier würde ich gerne einhängen die kirche muss es
gott recht machen die kirchen müssen dass gott
rechnung auf eine etwas mir noch lieber wäre
die christinnen und christen sondern es versuchen
gott recht zu machen und da habe ich schon meine
frage zeigen wie man es gott recht machen kann
und dann die grünen das größte geschenk und für
mich die wichtigste aller kräfte die liebe so
zu bewerten das geht für mich überhaupt nicht
auf ich bin überzeugt dass jede liebe zwischen
menschen die zum wohle der menschen beiträgt ein
geschenk gottes ist den segen gottes verdient
und alles andere ist qualifizieren da liebe sie
haben vorhin gesagt das tun sie nicht das tun sie
doch indem sie die er für alle ablehnen und sagen
die eine liebe hat einen institutionellen rahmen
verdient indem sie gewisse rechtliche zusprüche
auch ansprüche aber auch zusprüche hat und die
andere liebe hat das nicht verdient das ist ein
qualifizieren von beziehungen in dem das sie ganz
konkrete lebensrealitäten schaffen die auf der
einen seite einfacher ist um diese beziehung zu
leben und auf der anderen seite schwieriger wenn
sie daran denken dass zum beispiel homosexuelle
paare rechtlich einen viel schlechteren schutz
haben aus heterosexuelle paare das kann doch
nicht angehen also spiele ich wollte hier
die ja über die bibel diskutieren ich denke jetzt
mal dahin sie haben in einem interview gesagt er
ist gottes erfindung ab sie haben ja vorhin auch
diese ewigen werte angesprochen können sie das
kurz aus führen also sie werden wahrscheinlich
biblischer argumentieren inwiefern ist ehe
zwischen mann und frau gott dass er weniger
wir können den schöpfungsbericht liest also
ich glaube das liegt zwischen testament im buch
genesis genau und jesus bezieht sich ja dann auch
im neuen testament wieder darauf bezieht sich
auf das moralische gesetz stellt sich auch dazu
ich glaube diese beiden testamente die gehören ja
auch zusammen und es geht um die frage ob wir die
hebe griff neu definieren wollen oder nicht skaten
für mich nicht um die frage der lebensqualität der
beziehungsqualität ich glaube nicht aber dass ein
heterosexuelles paar passe eine bessere liebe hat
überhaupt nicht aber verlieren sie können doch
nicht allen ernstes hinter dem begriff stehen
den der uns in den biblischen schriften entgegen
kommt also die geräten von biblischen schriften
die in einer komplett patriarchalen gesellschaft
geschrieben wurden die frau ist der besitz des
mannes die ehe hat nur dazu regal beigetragen
dass die frau von einem haus stand diesmal es
nämlich von dem von ihrem vater in den anderen
ihres mannes dann ging was die frau dazu meint
habe überhaupt nichts zur sache getan wenn der
mann der frau überdrüssig war hat er sie haut
entlassen aus dem bestand hat sich oder sonst
noch 23 dazu genommen oder bei seinen 1000 das
ist der biblische betreffen weil wir wirklich
daran christus hat sich sehr klar gegen die cent
lassen zb gestellt und in der schöpfung steht auch
nichts davon dass man frauen schlecht behandeln
soll aber in der schöpfung steht nichts von ehe
in der schöpfung ersten schöpfungsbericht steht
wie leben entsteht da steht nichts von mir ehe
ist ein kulturgeschichtlicher begriff dazu recht
da man sich luther zitieren er ist ein weltlich
ding das sollen die religionsgemeinschaften sowie
so vorsichtig sein zu sagen wie er dann wir
hier schließen darf und wer nicht ich finde
das richtig dass man das dem staat übergeben hat
aber so wie sie das darstellen in den ähren im
ersten schöpfungsbericht ist nichts von ihm
zu reden schlägst du es bezieht sich aber ja
darauf christus war da wirklich feminist als er
gesagt hat dies könnte ja nicht machen neuere
frauen nicht einfach entlassen deshalb das war
auch das was man heute als konservativ an sieht
auch das ist gegen die scheidung das war ganz
wichtig für die frau dass die einfach nicht aus
dem ehestand entlassen werden konnte sie haben
wohl gemeint der mensch soll nicht trennen was
gott verbunden hat oder dass man zum schutz
der frau das kann man heute das ist ja dass
das könnten wir auch streitfragen scheidungen
machen auch das ist heute nicht mehr 12 es
anzuwenden ich bitte doch wirklich an die an
die zeitgeschichtlichen bedingungen sagt der
gute der biblischen schriften zu denken sonst
nehmen wir die biblischen schriften nicht ernst
und dafür ist im team ihr zu lieb das ja ja wir
haben einen konflikt zwischen einer wörtlichen
auslegung und eine historisch kritisch nach
ich weiß nicht es brauche ich das von außen
menschen die herankommen an die bibel sagen so
steht sie eröffnen das 1 sie wollten reagieren
ich bin über ein bibelwort gestolpert gestern
vorgestern im galater was paulus geschrieben
hat und das ist mir so hat mich sehr gefreut
dass ist weil paulus sagt da da ist weder juden
noch grieche wieder sklaven noch noch 3 2 weder
mann noch frau wir sind alle eins in christus
und ich habe wieder nachgedacht das möchte ich
auch noch in dieser runde in dieser runde sagen
weil wir sind eben wir sind verschiedene meinung
aber schlussendlich und das ist manchmal auch
mein traum dass ich auch als lesbische frau
dass ich in einen gottesdienst gehen kann da
sind einfach alle arten von menschen in diesem
gottesdienst also familien alleinstehende alle
familienformen grauens menschen alles ist da und
wir konzentrieren uns auf jesus und wir sind es
ist egal weil gott hat uns alle so geschaffen und
er liebt uns darf ich nur einen einsatz aus dem
ersten testament anfügen und ziehe es war sehr
gut die schöpfung ist gut leben wir endlich so
dass die schöpfung gut es dass jeder mensch
so wie geschaffen ist gut es ich denke hier
beispiel mit dem galaterbrief nicht mehr sklaven
und frei ist normal ein beleg für das was frau
vorausgesagte man muss biblische texte in ihrem
historischen hintergrund verstehen denn auch die
sklaverei ist damals nicht abgeschafft worden
hat aber etwas damit zu tun gehabt dass paulus
unter der erwartung des reiches gottes stand
und hat gesagt wenn sowieso das reich gottes
gleich bald beginnt ja dann brauchen wir nicht
große gesellschafts verordnung noch verändern
sondern hat den sklaven aufgefordert geht
wieder zurück und hat den herren aufgefordert
gut mit dem sklaven was mich interessiert ist
in der intention glaube ich sind wir gar nicht
so unterschiedlich sie möchten doch den wert
der liebe zu der beziehung der liebe zwischen
zwei menschen schützen jetzt frage ich mich
was ist ihnen jetzt wichtiger die hülle die
form muss die auch per see gerettet werden
egal was da innerhalb des gefüges passiert
oder geht es nicht darum 1 korinther 13 zu sagen
was sind die qualitätsmerkmale der liebe die für
beziehungsqualität gefördert werden sollten und
dann ist für mich das beispiel es wird geöffnet
es wird nichts genommen ich verstehe überhaupt
nicht das problem wenn ich mit meiner lebensform
als mit einer frau verheiratet plusminus
zufrieden bin da gibt es immer auf und ab
bedroht nicht ob nicht das andere anders leben
sondern was für mich spannend ist wie gehen
wir miteinander in der grund sehnsucht um nach
nahen verlässlichen dauerhaft und ganzheitlichen
beziehung ich bin mir nicht sicher wer bei mit
der bibel weiterkommen weil ich glaube dass wir
einfach zitieren was uns gefällt aber wir können
es noch mit der tradition versuchen das hat peter
von suri auch versucht könnten sie uns dazu
etwas sagen ist es nicht so dass die ehe in
der katholischen oder in der tradition der kirche
doch eher zum schutz von kindern und frauen er
von ihr nicht so sehr auf die bibel zurück geht
lange hat sich die katholische kirche um er hier
überhaupt nicht gekümmert das muss man auch sehen
sondern sie hat ja also das die ehe als sakrament
gibt es ja es hat im zwölften jahrhundert und dort
wurde zum schutz der frauen zb eingeführt eine ehe
muss öffentlich und fahrzeugen stattfinden einmal
um die zwangs und zwecken gerade der adelshäuser
einzuschränken und auch die heimlichen die
sogenannten klandestinen zu verbieten dass
da irgendein mann seiner holden das schönste
geschworen hatte in der dunkelheit und am nächsten
morgen sich nicht mehr erinnern konnte da ist
katholik ist die kirche also muss ich sagen ist
die kirche wirklich als anwalt der frauen stark
hat die sich stark gemacht hat gesagt wir müssen
die frauen schützen sie sind die schwächeren und
deswegen öffentlich und fahrzeugen das ist ein
gewinn und dann nochmal auch ausdrücklich als
sakrament übrigens schon seit dem vierten 401
von augustinus er hat bewusst dass als sakrament
bezeichnet nur da spielte er noch so unter dem
aspekt zunächst muss nachkommenschaft gesichert
werden und dann treue und sakrament der das
bemühen nachkommenschaft ist jetzt nicht speziell
kirchlich ist alle ordnungen wollten sicherstellen
wie wird das weitervererbt und sonst war selbst
habe ich gelesen im katholischen bayern hat ein
bauer erstmal erst dann geheiratet wenn sicher
war dass seine auserwählte auch nachwuchs bekommen
ja der ist die katholische kirche auch in ihrer
eigenen sexualmoral sehr zwiespältig von daher
sehe als rechtsinstitut um etwas wichtiges von
zwei menschen zu schützen ich glaube da können
wir uns verständigen ja die frage ist ob die
öffnung das ganze bedroht oder die durch das
nennen auch anreichert darüber müssen wir
diskutieren ich gerne ein bisschen über
zum beispiel diese vehemenz zu sagen ja das ist
jetzt ebenso die weltweite kirche sieht das ja
ganz anders es gibt in der weltweiten kirche wenn
wir auch in den kirchen in asien in den wachsenden
kirchen auch umfragen machen würden dann gibt es
längst nicht diese breite zustimmung zum beispiel
zum öffnung eines begriffs sagen wir den ja wir
haben hier im westen die wahrheit gepachtet und
alle anderen haben es noch nicht verstanden
ich das finde ich auch nicht richtig da hat
es für mich auch etwas moralisieren das drinnen
solcher kirchen sind ja ich denke katholische
kirche reformen römisch-katholische freikirchen
einfach wir reden jetzt über und zum beispiel
darüber dass es in der schweiz nur noch eine
kleine minderheit ist die eröffnung des ebel
ist nicht zustimmen will weltweit gesehen ist das
aber ganz anders und meine frage ist einfach haben
wir hier im westen denn einfach per sehr echt oder
müssten wir nicht auch diesen kontext einbeziehen
eine gesellschaft haben würden sie auch wie peter
von suri mit der tradition argumentieren es hat
sich bewährt ich glaube dass die tradition ein
argument ist dass man sich überlegen soll also
dieser respekt vor der weisheit auch ein
traditioneller sie ist nicht für mich ist
es nicht die tradition die letztlich entscheidend
ist sondern für mich ist es diese erkenntnis die
ich in meiner beziehung zu gott im bibel lesen das
ist eine andere aus sie finden aber ich glaube sie
verdient den gleichen respekt ja respekt bin ich
sehr an ihr stand nur noch mal den hinweis auch
von frau cora schon mal die art wie wir bibel
lesen ich nehme ein beispiel es gibt zinsverbot
es gibt verbot zu schwören nennt niemanden
euren vater als den himmlischen ja es gibt
es gibt die auf forderungen deutscher nur alle
sieben jahre schuldenerlass zu machen ich habe
noch alle wunderbar ja ich habe noch nie gehört
dass mit gleicher vehemenz das eingefordert wird
das ist das was die gemeinde
bibel zitieren vertrieb wurde
noch angesprochen von peter von sony
ist das einfach ein trick wenn sie zum
beispiel gleichgeschlechtliche paare
segnen um sie in der kirche zu halten
habe ich mir noch gar nicht überlegt nein also ich
sags noch mal ich bin alles reformierte theologe
jetzt weniger an der tradition verpflichtet
weniger ich habe haben keine lehrmeinung
die für uns gilt aber ich bin den heiligen
schriften ich bin den biblischen schriften
verpflichtet und selbstverständlich nehme ich
sie in ihrer auslegung der bibel ernst ich kann
ihnen einfach aus theologin sagen ich finde sie
fragwürdig das stimmt dass wir genau ich weil
ich einen sonst hätte ich auch nicht sechs
jahre studieren müssen um einfach die bibel
aufzuschlagen und dann an zu streichen das passt
mir und das passt nämlich und das haben sie jetzt
gerade wichtig angesprochen oder man kann die
bibel nicht wörtlich lesen man kann sie nicht
selektiv lesen ich kann nicht im buch articus
anstreichen wenn ein mann bei einem mann liegt
wie sie bei einer frau während meiner frau liegt
dann sind sie des todes und daneben kleidung aus
zwei unterschiedlichen materialien sind sie auch
des todes dass es jetzt veraltet dass andere gilt
nicht so kann man mit den biblischen texten nicht
umgehen was mir aber am meisten am herzen liegt
ist das evangelium von jesus christus und hier
finde ich wirklich kommen wir unter umständen
einen nicht ganz angenehmen konflikt denn jesus
sagt liebt einander wie ich euch geliebt habe
das ist vorbehaltlose liebe einander die wir
einander entgegen bringen sollen das höchste
gebot neben der gottesliebe ist die nächstenliebe
und in der umsetzung der ehe für alle das heißt
dass wir nicht mehr qualifizieren zwischen
wirklich verantwortungsvollen liebesbeziehungen
seien wir doch als christin ohne testen froh
dass ich menschen dazu verpflichten wollen
verantwortungsvolle beziehungen einzugehen das
ist doch irrsinn als christinnen und christen
zu sagen nein das wollen wir nicht das ist doch
was wir wollen das ist doch was wir hochhalten
wollen die liebe zwischen den menschen die
verantwortungsvolle liebe die auch in unserer
gesellschaft strahlen soll und deshalb finde ich
dir für alle muss ein grundsätzlich christliches
anliegen sein wenn man das evangelium
von jesus christus ernst gut galt trick
kein trick ich möchte gern einen schritt
weiter gehen bei der frage welche rechte
für gleichgeschlechtliche paare gehen in einer
ehe wenn es um die familienbildung geht und wie
das geht hat das fernsehen ein dokumentarfilm
gezeigt mit jerome und patrick sie sind ein paar
das dank einer leihmutter in den usa sind
die beiden väter geworden von zwillingen
wir schauen uns kurz einen ausschnitt an wie
die beiden mit den zwillingsbabys nach hause
gekommen sind in die schweiz am 29 januar
2018 kommen jérome an patrick mit klara und
nathan in genf an was empfanden sie in den
ersten augenblicken mit ihren babys liebe
und einem gefühl der erfüllung das gefühl dass
die familie jetzt komplett ist das bewusstsein
für sie da zu sein um sie zu beschützen und
das ist fast wie ein versprechen das wir
ihnen gegeben haben als wir sie in den arm
nahmen ich sagte ich werde für dich da sein
das hat mich auch sehr berührt verträgt mit
einem unserer kinder auf dem arm zu sehen
wie schwierig das andere hielt lockere
war ich war stolz dass wir es geschafft
haben und sehr gerührt große rührung auch
beim abschied von lindsay die herzen waren
schwer die tränen flossen das war von anfang
an der moment vor dem ich die größte angst
hatte ich wusste das würde sehr schwierig da
hat es sonst schon sehr geholfen zu wissen
dass wir sie in ein paar monaten wieder sehen
lege wert auf einladung des paares im oktober
anreisen um patrick herum und die kinder die
sie ausgetragen hat zu sehen es ist schwer
unsere dankbarkeit in dem maße zu zeigen wie wir
das gerne tun würden ich finde keine worte dafür
eigentlich hat sie unsere familie möglich gemacht
ja was lösen die bilder bei hinaus v.li ich bin
immer gerührt wenn ich bei wie sie
auch nach 18 jahren noch aufheben
und sonst finde ich es einfach ich finde es
wunderbar wenn zwei menschen die sich lieben
auch familie gründen und was mir aber auch
gerade wichtig ist bei diesem punkt und zu
unserem heutiger zu unserer heutigen streitfrage
in der ehe für alle ist leihmutterschaft kein
thema wissenschaft nicht für mich das ist frei
mutterschaft in der schweiz ist verboten ich
möchte das möchte ich ganz klar sagen dass das
nicht zur diskussion steht in dieser vorlag
das war ja auch in den usa dann nicht in der
schweiz wie beurteilen sie es denn in der runde
also dieser vorschlag der rechtskommission
des nationalrates beinhaltet ganz klar die
adoption von kindern in de wenn sie denn kommt
für gleichgeschlechtliche paare wie beurteilen
sie das ich glaube es steht noch nicht für
diskussionen diese vorlage bestimmt nicht der
druck steigt ab weil er uns familie sind auch
untrennbar irgendwo miteinander verbunden darf
ich das klären im vorschlag der rechtskommission
solang es steht die aktion drin es steht in einem
bei gefühlten vorschlag die samenspende drin als
variante aber die adoption aus dem vorschlag drin
sein aber sie sehr glücklich aber ich denke der
druck steigt weil zwei männer ja nicht ohne eine
frau ein kind bekommen können und für mich fremd
spenden und leihmutterschaft die möchte ich auch
für heterosexuelle paare nicht aus sie nicht dass
wir die themen durcheinanderbringt ich rede von
adoption wie beurteilen sie die automation von
mir durch gleichgeschlechtliche paare ich glaube
dass ein kind auf mutter und vater entsteht
und auch bei seinen biologischen eltern leben
soll wo immer das möglich ist unfall gegen
geschlechtlichen eltern leben soll einfach
aus diesem entstehen heraus ich glaube dass das
sinn macht dass wir das alle welt und das ist
ja nicht mal bei einer adoption heterosexuelles
paar genau aber ich denke auch da wo das nicht
möglich ist dass das kind bei einem vater und bei
einer mutter so einfach sollte weil ich glaube
dass das für das kind ein förderndes gegenüber
eine fördernde spannung ist ich weiß aber doch
es zeigen bis zu 100 studien international
inzwischen dass kinder in regenbogenfamilien
genauso glücklich und gesund aufwachsen können
wie kinder in herkömmlichen familien das finde
ich etwas ganz ganz wichtiges und wir leben
ja auch in einer gesellschaft wo so viele
verschiedene familienformen nach gibt es gibt der
patchworkfamilien es gibt eben die herkömmliche
familie es gibt ein eltern familien und es gibt
regenbogenfamilien und ich finde das auch ganz
wichtig dass diese kinder eben auch geschützt
sind weil das sind sie heute nicht als sie würden
klar für das recht auf adoption blättchen nicht
nur das recht auf adoption sondern auch diese
zweite variante die auch in die vernehmlassung
geht das recht auf den zugang zur künstlichen
befruchtung für lesbische verheiratete paare und
das argument dass dort dann ungleich behandelt
würden die schwulen paar homosexuelles kann
ich so gar nicht nachvollziehen weil es ist
die rechtslage in der schweiz ist so dass eben
leihmutterschaft ist verboten und es geht in
dieser variante geht es darum dass quasi das
eigentlich dass verheiratete lesbische frauen
den gleichen zugang zur verpflanzung medizin
haben wie heterosexuelle paare darf ich noch
mal zurück auf sie zu also bei der frage der
adoption beeindruckt mich am meisten dass
menschen nicht nur auf sich bezogen sind sondern
sich auch öffnen verantwortung zu übernehmen für
ein kind das ist für mich das beeindruckendste die
frage die sie dann als nächstes angesprochen dann
braucht es nicht vater und mutter also das ist
die leben ja nicht einem atomisierten raum also
das baby jetzt mit zwei männern oder mit zwei
frauen sondern die sind ja auch eingebunden mit
freunden bekannten frauen und männern wo eine
vielfalt auch erlebbar wird das einzige wo ich
jetzt unsicher bin ist was die alltäglichkeit
angeht ja aber ich kann mich erinnern dass
ich mal gelesen habe dass zum beispiel auch
die kinder heranwachsen kindergarten schule
auch mit anderen zusammen kommen und ihre innere
geschlechtliche biologische identität leben können
und nicht deswegen weil sie bei zwei männern oder
zwei frauen aufwachsen automatisch genauso die
gleiche orientierung haben was meinen sie mit
alltäglichkeit ja in der woche miteinander tag
das mache ich jetzt da sehen wir studien klar die
sie zitieren oder aber die studien sind sehr jung
das phänomen ist nein das phänomen ist noch sehr
jung ich glaube um verlässliche aussagen zu machen
die studien habe ich genau angeschaut die kindheit
zurück verlässt sie sind wirklich so zahlreich
und sie dann wirklich zum schluss dass hier die
kinder keinen nachteil weder medizinisch noch in
ihrer entwicklung erleiden ich würde gerne noch
ein haken bei dem ein kind braucht eine mutter
und einen vater war es selbstverständlich
braucht es eine biologische frau und einem
biologischen mann und ein dienstmädchen zu zeugen
wir sind jetzt aber bei der adoption das heißt bei
kindern die aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht bei
ihren leiblichen eltern leben können und wenn
man dann sagt es braucht eine biologische
frau und einen biologischen man um dieses
kind großzuziehen weil nur eine biologische frau
mutter sein kann und nur ein biologischer vater
das entspricht überhaupt nicht meine meine männer
und frauen meinem menschenbild ich als biologische
frau kann hoffen ich genauso gut vater sein dh
diese eigenschaften haben die man einem vater
zuspricht wie mein mann mutter sein kann dass
diese eigenschaften in sich trägt oder ausleben
kann die man sonst einer mutter zu spricht ich
finde das ganz schwierig zu sagen als biologische
frau muss ich die mütterlichen eigenschaften haben
und als biologischer man muss sich die väterlichen
eigenschaften haben das führt mich auch dazu zum
beispiel dass es eine sehr große geringschätzung
meistens der männer ist es ist nicht umsonst
dass wir noch keine vaterschaftsurlaub haben
weil man den männern noch viel zu wenig nützlich
und mütterliche eigenschaften zutraute und wenn
ich den sehr rührenden film dieser zwei männer
ich kann mir jetzt thema leihmutterschaft aus
aber diese große liebe diese fürsorge dieser zwei
männer das ist doch mütterlich würden wir sagen
das sind denke ich erkennbar biologische männer
möchte aber jetzt noch beim das sind interessante
bilder mann/frau cg jung animus anima was wir in
uns tragen welche bilder wir realisieren im alltag
habe ich möchte noch mal zurück auf diesen zweiten
vorschlag der rechtskommission des nationalrates
ist eine variante ich betone dass mit samenspende
jetzt frage ich doch mal wir hatten eine zeit da
war es nicht selbstverständlich dass katholiken
katholiken reformierte und umgekehrt geheiratet
haben also zwischen den konfessionen sie haben
die eingetragene partnerschaft heute wir stehen
möglicherweise vor der ehe für alle kommt dann
die samenspende kommt dann die öffnung wie sie
sagen für die fortpflanzungsmedizin kommt dann
die leihmutterschaft ist das hier salamitaktik
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der druck darauf
steigt wir sind im moment ganz stark auch darauf
ausgerichtet was wünscht sich der einzelne stadt
vielleicht auch zu fragen was braucht das ganze
was braucht der staat ich glaube dass dieser druck
steigen wir geben ich finde eben auch 40 jahre
studie nicht lange ich finde das nicht eine lange
zeit klar wir brauchen noch mehr zeit um darüber
nachzudenken und ich persönlich glaube nicht dass
es für kinder gut ist aus spenden spende dass die
spende von samenzellen einzeller zum beispiel
glaube ich nicht dass das der identität des
kindes förderlich ist die kinderrechtskonvention
sagt ja auch dass kinder das recht haben bei
ihren geologischen eltern seines opfers wenn es
also bei ihnen nicht samenspender und sie gesagt
ja leihmutterschaft ist ja konsens nein ich bin
suchend besuchen was ich denke wirklich dass ich
für mich ich habe so ein bisschen für mich ist das
problem ich möchte gerne die fortpflanzungsmedizin
wirklich trennen von der frage für alle weil ich
finde hier wird auch ein bisschen eine unheilbare
allianz nach zum teil taktisch gemacht weil man
eben dann diese szenarien und dann kommt das alles
und so ich finde es ist wichtig dass wir über
die zugang den zugang zur fortpflanzungsmedizin
sprechen aber völlig unabhängig ob da jetzt den
homo oder hetero sexuellen paaren offen stehen
soll sondern einfach dieses thema nehmen da bin
ich beim thema leihmutterschaft natürlich äußerst
kritisch auch aus feministischer sicht kritisch
ich befürchte es könnte zu einer ausbeutung der
frau kommen zu einer körperlichen ausbeutung der
frau ist könnte finanzielle druck geben auf auf
frauen gerade auch aus armen ländern ich finde
da braucht es ganz genaue vorsichtsmaßnahmen
wurde auch schon diskutiert und landwirtschaft
zum beispiel nicht mehr bezahlt werden darf oder
dass dieses argument vom tisch ist dass man sagt
diese diesen menschen lassen sie uns diese frauen
lassen sich kaufen ist ich finde es gibt gute
gründe die man gegen leihmutterschaft ins feld
führen kann respektive weil man sehr kritisch
sein muss das nicht zu einer ausbeutung der frau
kommt aber tatsache ist ja dass wir eine ganz
lange zeit nicht darüber diskutiert haben dass
das jetzt plötzlich dieser konsens wie nicht
mehr da ist der ganz lange da war dass es für
heterosexuelle paare klar war leihmutterschaft
das ist gott das war schweiz gar kein thema bis
vor kurzem nur schwangere ich rede mit dem zu
was vor gesagt hat das geht mir ähnlich ich hab
noch mal versucht vom kind her zu denken es wird
irgendwann die frage kommen wo ein kind wissen
möchte wer ist meine mutter wer ist mein vater
und wie gehe ich damit um dass das weiß ich jetzt
dabei das weiß ich jetzt von von den nutzern
zum thema leihmutterschaft von männer paaren
die über leihmutter ein kind oder auch zwillinge
bekommen haben dass die den kontakt dass es ihnen
sehr wichtig ist den kontakt weiter zu pflegen
mit dieser leim und dass das dass diese kinder
also haben wir an diesem beitrag auch gehört dass
die kinder wissen wer war diese frau und die art
uns ausgetragen das wäre die positive variante
vorrat auf die andere aufmerksam gemacht die
mich einfach unsicher macht gedacht haben gesagt
schwanken ich komme zu einer schlussrunde sie
merken wir kommen nach zum ende unseres gesprächs
wie beurteilen sie ist wenn die ehe für alle kommt
wie werden die kirchen die kirche gemeinschaften
die christlichen gemeinschaften reagieren
ja man kann heute offen dann schauen wir werden
die christlichen gemeinschaften reagieren es
wird es wird ganz viel diskussion geben und ich
hoffe ich hoffe aber auch dass wir dass wir auch
ins gespräch miteinander gehen und das ist nicht
einfach diese zwei lager gibt von von von menschen
die er für alle von vornherein ablehnen und
solchen die aber danach finden wie wir mit denen
die das ableben gar nicht reden die reformierte
kirche kirchen reformierten landeskirche es gibt
noch sein dieser größte graben wo man weiß die
waadtländer kirch meine ich es dass die noch ein
bisschen kritischer eingestellt auch intel sollte
ja sonst ist eigentlich konsens die ehe für alle
bringt die trauung für alle und trotzdem möchte
ich betonen wir haben theologisch gesehen die
trauben für alle schon wir dürfen es nur nicht
so nennen wir sind also eigentlich auf kirche
mal vorreiterin der kreis schließt sich zu ihren
eingangsworten wie wird die römisch katholische
kirche reagieren ich glaube die irritation
wird noch anhalten ich hoffe aber auch dass
die besinnung auf gottes wort und die bereitschaft
gottes jedem den segen zuzusprechen auch ein neues
denken ermöglicht und nach dem sägen könnte auch
die heirat kommen zum beispiel wenn sakrament
heißt es geht um einen beziehungs zeichen zwei
menschen drücken ausmachen zeichenhaft sichtbar
wie die liebe zueinander auch noch mal die
nähe gottes zum menschen aus drückt also und
fällt für viele ist ja wichtig dass hier sagen
wir möchten das nicht als privat geschichte wir
möchten uns miteinander sehen lassen und gesehen
werden und wirklich auch anerkannt sein dass
hier geht's um anerkennung wertschätzung durch
auch öffentliche institutionelle in ordnung was
denken sie die freikirchen ich glaube freikirchen
landeskirchen werden sich darüber gedanken machen
wie man die persönliche freiheit der pfarrerin
der pfarrer gewährleisten kann dass diese je nach
ihren überzeugungen handeln dürfen und ich glaube
dass ich diese kurz reformierte freiheit position
auch beziehen zu dürfen nach dem eigenen gewissen
zu handeln und ich gehe davon aus dass das eine
diskussion sein wird wie gewährleisten wir diese
gewissensfreiheit könnte sein dass die katholiken
sich dann auf diese gut reformatorische tradition
berufen und sagen wir machen hier nicht mit wir
werden es sehen ich bedanke mich jedenfalls ganz
herzlich für diese diskussion hier mit ihnen
ganz herzlichen dank eva cavalli herr block
civil vor und frau lehmann und am nebentisch
ganz herzlichen dank ihnen für ihr interesse
auch für den warmen applaus hier geht es gleich
weiter mit der sternstunde philosophie und zwar
mit dem höchsten aller gefühle mit dem orgasmus
mit einem thema das bisher in der philosophie
offenbar noch wenig beachtung gefunden hat